e para que todo carnaval da merda comigo
tem uma vez vai tomar no carnaval só
cinco Tá daqui é diarreia ela tem três
níveis ela tem aquela aquela pontada que
ela te dá para te dizer assim olha não
tá tudo muito certo por aqui não que é
que você tem que ser localizada procurar
o lugar mais próximo Aí eu comecei a
andar aqui pelo meio do povo aqui só
assim ó aproveitando o ritmo da galera
aqui passando aqui no meio da galera
assim aí eu saí correndo comecei a minha
Hope aqui todinho me arrepiando sentindo
um calafrio é o segundo livro da
diarreia como se sente calafrios e
começa a se arrepiar os pelinhos assim
olha só guardar gente que eu tô chegando
em pé da televisão espelhinho começa a
subir assim aí eu cheguei no banheiro
público era o banheiro público não era o
banheiro químico que o banheiro químico
o banheiro químico uma coisa engraçada
de falar mas como fala banheiro químico
Eu imagino um próprio banheiro que faz a
merda dele ele pega as um negócio a
porção aí volta aqui e faça agora eu vou
criar um tô leitinho perder o banheiro
que mas não era esse era o banheiro
público aquele banheiro que é muitos
banheiro e é feito tipo pela prefeitura
assim aí eu entrei já tava até lá merda
aquela miséria assim sabe direito do
banheiro público Eu acho que o povo
pensa assim a República é é público eu
vou pagar na parede